HAVE A GOOD NIGHT, EVERYONE.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
YOU MAY HAVE SEEN CLIPS OF IT,
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI TESTIFIED
BEFORE CONGRESS TODAY TO EXPLAIN
HOW MUCH LONGER MESSED
QUARANTINES MUST LAST AND WHAT
OTHER SACRIFICES THE REST OF US
NEED TO MAKE IN ORDER TO FIGHT
THE WAR ON CORONAVIRUS.
DR. FAUCI HAS NEVER BEEN ELECTED
TO ANYTHING THAT YOU WOULD NEVER
KNOW IT, MANY OF OUR LEADERS
BELIEVE HIS EVERY WORD IS
TANTAMOUNT TO LAW AND IN FACT,
IT HAS BEEN.
JUST HOW WISE IS A MAN MAKING
THESE LAWS?
IS HE ROOTED IN SCIENCE?
WE WILL LET YOU DECIDE IN JUST A
MINUTE.
BUT FIRST NO MATTER HOW LONG
THESE LOCK DOWNS DO GO ON WE ARE
STARTING TO SEE THE OUTLINES OF
THE DAMAGE THEY CAUSE SO FAR.
A RECENT WORKING PAPER RELEASED,
AND MORE THAN 40% WILL BE GONE
FOREVER AND THOSE JOBS WILL
NEVER COME BACK EVEN ONCE ALL
GOVERNMENT RESTRICTIONS ARE
LIFTED.
NOW IF THAT TURNS OUT TO BE
TRUE, AND OF COURSE WE HOPE IT
ISN’T, BUT IF IT IS THAT WOULD
MEAN NEARLY 14 MILLION AMERICANS
WOULD BE LANGUISHING IN
LONG-TERM UNEMPLOYMENT.
FOR PERSPECTIVE, DURING THE
GREAT RECESSION OF 2008, WHOSE
EFFECTS WE FEEL EVEN NOW, JOB
LOSSES PEAKED AT 10 MILLION.
SO THIS IS AN UNPRECEDENTED
DISASTER FOR AMERICAN FAMILIES.
WHAT WE ARE LIVING THROUGH.
AND IT’S COMPOUNDING WHAT WAS
ALREADY THERE.
THANKS TO A SERIES OF UGLY
CHANGES, MANY PEOPLE WERE STUCK
IN JOBS WITH LOWER PAY AND FEWER
BENEFITS THAN THE ONES THEY LOST
A DECADE AGO.
MILLIONS HAVE NO SAVINGS AND ARE
SUFFOCATING BENEATH THE
MOUNTAINS OF STUDENT DEBT AND
CREDIT CARD DEBT.
THIS WAS ALREADY A COUNTRY WITH
DECLINING LIFE EXPECTANCY AND
GROWING EQUALITY IN THE
CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC ACCELERATED
THOSE TRENDS.
SO OUR MAIN JOB BEFORE ANYTHING
ELSE IS TO FIX THAT DAMAGE.
EVERYTHING DEPENDS ON FIXING IT.
SO THAT IS THE SAD BACKDROP TO
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES AND
NEW 18 PAGE CORONAVIRUS RELIEF
BILL WHICH WAS RELEASED TODAY.
ANYTHING OUR CONGRESS DOES AT
THE MOMENT MUST FIRST AND
FOREMOST PREVENT ORDINARY PEOPLE
FROM SLIPPING BENEATH THE WAVES.
IN A STATEMENT TODAY >>
NANCY PELOSI ASSURED VOTERS THAT
HER BILL COME THIS BILL, WILL DO
JUST THAT.
>> WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT WE CAN
OPEN AIR ECONOMY AS QUICKLY AS
WE CAN BUT WE MUST DO SO BASED
ON SCIENCE AND DATA.
WE MUST DO SO IN A WAY THAT
REACHES ALL AMERICANS IN A WAY
THAT ADDRESSES THE DISPARITIES
THAT WE HAVE SEEN, SO THAT WE
CAN ASSESS THE FULL EXTENT OF
THE CORONAVIRUS AND DEFEAT IT.
WE ALL KNOW THAT WE MUST PUT
MORE MONEY IN THE POCKETS OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
BUT IT IS ALSO A STIMULUS TO THE
ECONOMY.
DIRECT PAYMENTS, UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE, MORTGAGE HELP AND
FOOD AND STUDENT LOAN ASSISTANCE
AMONG OTHER THINGS ARE ESSENTIAL
TO RELIEVE THE FEAR THAT MANY
FAMILIES ARE FACING.
>> Tucker: AMONG OTHER THINGS,
SPEAKER PELOSI JUST SAID.
WHAT ARE THOSE THINGS?
FIRST THING TO KNOW ABOUT THIS
BILL IS THAT IT’S BIG, MAYBE THE
BIGGEST PIECE OF LEGISLATION
EVER PROPOSED IN U.S. HISTORY.
THE ESTIMATED PRICE TAG FOR
EVERYTHING IN THIS BILL IS
$3 TRILLION WHICH IS CLOSE TO
90% OF THE NATION’S ENTIRE
ANNUAL TAX REVENUE.
KEEP IN MIND THAT KEY COMES
CLOSE ON THE HEELS OF THE LAST
CORONAVIRUS RELIEF BILL WHICH
COST ABOUT $2 TRILLION.
OF COURSE OUR USUAL ANNUAL
SPENDING IS THERE.
ALTOGETHER THAT’S AN AWFUL LOT
OF EXPENSES AND EVERYTHING WILL
DOLLAR WILL HAVE TO BE BORROWED
BECAUSE THERE AREN’T ANY LEFT.
WHEN THE SMOKE HAS CLEARED FROM
ALL OF THE SPENDING, ONLY CHINA
WILL HAVE BAILED US OUT.
CHINA HAS THE STRONGEST BALANCE
SHEET IN THE WORLD.
AT THAT POINT, IT WILL BE THERE
VESSELS.
WE SPEND ALL DAY READING
PELOSI’S BILL TO FIND OUT.
TOO FEW HAVE DONE THAT, WE DID.
HERE’S WHAT WE FOUND.
FIRST AND MOST GLARINGLY RELINK
THE LAST THING WE NEED IS MORE
ILLEGAL LOW-WAGE OF WHAT LABOR
FROM ABROAD.
BUT THIS GOES OUT OF THE WAY TO
SUPPLY ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS WITH
BILLIONS OF TAXPAYER DOLLARS.
ACCORDING TO HOUSE DEMOCRATS,
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS MUST HAVE A
RIGHT TO HAVE THE $1200 CHECKS
THAT AMERICAN CITIZENS RECEIVED
IN THE LAST BILL.
THEY ALSO RECEIVED THE SAME
DIRECT PAYMENTS AS AMERICAN
CITIZENS GOING FORWARD.
THAT’S A GROUP THAT’S NOT EVEN
ALLOWED TO BE HERE.
AND THEN THE BILL CONTAINS AN
AMNESTY PROVISION FOR THE
DURATION OF THE CORONAVIRUS
CRISIS.
THAT’S SOMETHING WE WOULD LIKE
TO CEASE EXTENDED A VERY LONG
TIME, ALL ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
EMPLOYED IN SO-CALLED ESSENTIAL
SERVICES WOULD BE SHIFTED FROM
DEPORTATION.
THEIR EMPLOYER WOULD BE
SHIELDED, TOO.
PEOPLE WHO HIRE ILLEGAL ALIENS
WOULD NOT BE PROSECUTED.
THEY ARE CRITICAL TO PROVIDING
MEDICAL CARE FOR THE REST OF US.
CURRENT ESSENTIAL WORKERS AS
THEY ARE DEFINED IN THIS BILL IS
IN FACT AN ENORMOUS CATEGORY
THAT SPANS ALMOST EVERY PART OF
THE AMERICAN ECONOMY.
IT INCLUDES EMPLOYEES IN FOOD
SERVICES, LAUNDRY, WASTE
MANAGEMENT, CHILD CARE,
AGRICULTURE AND RESTAURANTS.
AS WELL AS ANY RETAIL WORKER IN
AMERICA WHO WORKS AT A LOCATION
THAT SELLS FOOD OR BEVERAGES.
THIS IS A BLANKET AMNESTY FOR
VIRTUALLY EVERY ILLEGAL ALIEN
WHO HAS ALREADY TAKEN AN
AMERICAN JOB AND ONCE THE
AMNESTY IS GRANTED IT WILL NEVER
BE TAKEN AWAY.
THAT ON THAT, NO MATTER WHAT
THEY TELL YOU.
ANYONE WHO LIVES IN WASHINGTON
CAN CONFIRM THAT.
ONCE PAST, IT’S NOT GOING AWAY.
AT THAT POINT THERE WILL BE NO
MORE DEBATE ABOUT ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION AND THE ISSUE WILL
BE SETTLED PERMANENTLY.
DEMOCRATS WILL WIN EVERY
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION FOR THE
REST OF YOUR LIFE, THE REST OF
YOUR CHILDREN’S LIVES AND THAT’S
THE POINT OF THIS.
BUT THE BILL KEEPS GOING FROM
THERE.
THE BILL WOULD EXTEND CURRENT
VISAS AND THE DEMOCRATS COULD
CALL THIS BILL THE HEROES ACT.
THEY ARE TELLING YOU IT WILL
HELP HEALTH CARE WORKERS.
AS OF TONIGHT THOUSANDS OF
AMERICAN HEALTH CARE WORKERS ARE
BEING FURLOUGHED FROM THEIR JOBS
OR FIRED ENTIRELY.
THIS BILL REMARKABLY ORDERS DHS
TO EXPEDITE VISA PROCESSING FOR
FOREIGNERS WHO WANT TO COME TO
THE U.S. AND WORK IN HEALTH CARE
HEALTH CARE.
GOT THAT?
AMERICAN HEALTH CARE WORKERS
LAID OFF AND NOW THEY COULD BE
REPLACED BY FOREIGNERS WILLING
TO WORK FOR LESS.
WE DON’T HAVE TO GUESS IF THAT
WILL HAPPEN, IT’S HAPPENED
THROUGHOUT AMERICAN INDUSTRIES.
UNDER THIS BILL IT WOULD HAPPEN
TO OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS AS
WELL.
SORRY UNEMPLOYED AMERICANS,
BETTER GET USED TO DRAWING A
GOVERNMENT CHECK.
THEN THERE IS A LONG SECTION IN
THIS LEGISLATION ABOUT DRUGS,
THE BILL IS STRONGLY IN FAVOR OF
DRUGS PROBABLY BECAUSE WHEN YOU
ARE HIGH YOU ARE LESS LIKELY TO
THINK OR WORRY ABOUT WHAT ELSE
IS IN THE BILL.
THE BILL MENTIONS CANNABIS 68
TIMES.
IN ORDER FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO PRODUCE AN ANNUAL
REPORT, EXPANDING ACCESS TO
FINANCIAL SERVICES FOR MINORITY
OWNED AND CANNABIS OWNED
MAJORITY BUSINESSES.
PEOPLE ARE CALLING YOU A RACIST
AND, IT ORDERS ALL FEDERAL
AGENCIES TO THE GREATEST EXTENT
POSSIBLE TO HOLD DEPOSITS IN
MINORITY OWNED BANKS.
OKAY, FINE.
BUT WHAT IS THE PANDEMIC AND OUR
RESPONSE TO IT HAVE TO DO WITH
RACE POLITICS?
STUPID QUESTION.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY WILL COMIC
PARTY, EVERYTHING HAS TO DO WITH
RACE POLITICS ALL THE TIME.
IT’S A PRIMARY WAY THEY GET AND
KEEP POWER.
RACE POLITICS IS THE ONLY
PROGRAM THEY HAVE COME UP WITH
MORE CRIME AND INCREASED
CENSORSHIP.
THAT ALSO CONTAINS PRISON BREAK
PROVISION.
THIS BILL WOULD ORDER THE
RELEASE OF EVERY FEDERAL
PRISONER WHO HAS ASTHMA,
DIABETES OR IS OVER 50 YEARS OF
AGE, UNLESS THE BUREAU OF
PRISONS AFFIRMATIVELY PROVES
THATINMATE IN QUESTION IS PROVEN
COMMIT VIOLENCE AGAINST A
SPECIFIC PERSON.
AND HERE IS THE CENSORSHIP PART.
IT’S PART OF A GROWING AND
OMINOUS THEME IN THAT DIRECTION,
THE THEME WILL PREVENT YOU FROM
SAYING OR BELIEVING WHAT YOU
LIKE.
THIS BILL DIRECTS MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO THE NATIONAL SCIENCE
FOUNDATION TO STUDY THE
CORONAVIRUS "MISINFORMATION" WE
SHOULDN’T BE ALLOWED.
IN OTHER WORDS SHUT UP AND STOP
DISAGREE WITH OUR ANNOUNCEMENTS.
THAT’S A MESSAGE THAT IT SENDS.
BUT FOR THE FAVORED FEW, THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY’S DONOR CLASS,
THE BILL IS FAR MORE GENTLE.
THIS BILL WOULD REPEAL THE CAP
ON STATE AND LOCAL TAX
DEDUCTIONS.
THAT WOULD HELP ALMOST
EXCLUSIVELY HIGH INCOME
NEIGHBORHOODS IN OVERTAXED BLUE
STATES.
WHY IS THAT SIGNIFICANT?
THAT’S A BEATING HEART OF THE
DEMOCRATIC ELECTORATE.
THIS IS A PAYOFF TO THEM.
AMAZINGLY, YOU CAN’T MAKE THIS
UP.
THIS IS A VERY DIFFERENT KIND OF
HERO.
HE WOULD MAKE LOBBYING SHOPS IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., AND WROTE THIS
THING?
PROBABLY NOT SCIENTISTS.
LOBBYISTS AND IDEOLOGUES WROTE
IT, THE SAME PEOPLE WHO CONTROL